concern among firefighters nationwide
about a potential on-the-job hazard that
they say they face
cancer is already the leading cause of
death among firefighters and there's a
fresh theory about why we spoke with
some 44 firefighters who filed lawsuits
this week alleging that the gear they
wear designed to protect them from fires
is also making them sick many in the
firefighting community believe that
toxins are not only present in the fires
themselves the old theory but also in
their so-called turnout gear the
lawsuits claim chemicals used to make
that gear flame water and oil resistant
carry a hidden danger that can cause
devastating illness
this is a current set of turnover that i
would wear if i was working at the
firehouse veteran brockton massachusetts
firefighter joe marchetti wore gear like
this on almost every call for years this
set of gear is actually made so that we
can have a harness inside rising through
the ranks to become deputy chief of his
department to see it say brockton
deputies got to give you a sense of
pride
it took a lot of hard work but now he
won't let this iconic symbol of the job
once worn as almost a second skin
make it past the garage i won't bring it
into my house with what we know about
the turnout gear now and the chemicals
that are in it in 2016 at the age of 46
marchetti was diagnosed with prostate
cancer a diagnosis he alleges was caused
by exposure to chemicals in that gear
chemicals known as pfas per and
polyfluorokill substances last year a
blood test revealed marchetti's pfas
levels were significantly elevated above
the general population these chemicals
have been known to cause harm
for a long time
and this gear was being supplied to us
to protect us pfas are a group of
artificial compounds that make pans
non-stick and materials waterproof for
fire retardant among other things but
new lawsuits also claim they're
associated with adverse health effects
including cancer in the protective gear
worn by firefighters they're called the
forever chemicals and once we
manufacture some of them they last
forever they just migrate through
different systems if they're inhaled or
ingested by humans they'll end up in
your body and they'll stay there for
many years university of notre dame
physics professor graham peasley had
already been studying the presence of
pifas in the environment when the wife
of another firefighter with prostate
cancer convinced him to take a look at
the turnout gear so this is where the
beam particles will come out of the
accelerator at the nuclear research lab
on campus his team analyzed 30 different
sets of protective gear noting an outer
shell a moisture barrier and a thermal
liner we observe the p-fast there at
high quantities and they come off the
outer layer of the skier was really
highly fluorinated and the moisture
barrier was really highly fluorinated
and that's bad that's bad subsequent
studies co-authored by peasley confirm
the presence of phos and other turnout
gear his research has been cited in the
lawsuits
meanwhile the firefighting community is
grappling with staggering rates of
cancer since 2015 nearly three out of
four firefighters added to the iaff
fallen firefighter memorial have died
from so-called occupational cancer
even more have been diagnosed i was kind
of hit like a mack truck mark stelling a
fire captain for the city of gilroy
california found out he had stage one
cancer after an accident caused a tumor
on his kidney to burst when i was laid
out in that hospital bed for eight days
that was
belittling to me because i thought of
myself as pretty tough guy
but
laying there helpless trying to figure
out what was going on
that was a whole another game
retired san jose california fire
investigator teresa malden battled
multiple cancers i had breast cancer in
both breasts i had a double mastectomy
and then the fourth year
the bladder cancer reoccurred so for
four years i battled
and i just
couldn't stay on the job all three of
you are cancer free as we speak
no
and retired san jose fire captain dan
stapp has undergone radiation and
hormone therapy for prostate cancer from
what i understand is it's just going to
be there and just depends how aggressive
we take care of it how aggressive the
cancer itself gets
all three believe they would have been
cancer free if not for their uniforms
they joined a lawsuit in 2020 alleging
that pfos in their gear caused their
illnesses they're seeking damages from
companies that make pfos and manufacture
turnout gear what part of your brain if
any part was considering the risk of the
gear you were wearing
zero
nothing never your gear was almost
attached to your hip their training and
everything else was okay you're gonna go
do dangerous stuff you're to do the best
to protect yourself put this gear on and
go do it it was so ingrained in us it
was a safety thing this was the thing
that i wore it was the thing that i let
my daughter dress up in because she
wanted to look like mom would you
recommend this line of work for your
children and grandchildren
i steered my daughter away from it
you don't want your kids to go through
this
it seems like it was a hard conversation
to
have still is
you know your kids look up to you
they thought i was invincible this is my
son
as for marchetti he married into a
firefighting family so it was only
natural that his son would follow
you are the
wife of a firefighter the daughter of a
firefighter the granddaughter of a
firefighter
and the mother
marchetti's wife jen has always known
that there were risks associated with
the profession it's a dangerous job and
you know that to know that his gear
that's meant to protect him and keep him
from harm
harmed him and changed him
it makes me
it makes me angry it makes me angry and
it could potentially change my other
family members your son my son i can't i
can't even fathom it marquetti joins
dozens of firefighters in new lawsuits
also seeking damages from pfas makers
and turnout manufacturers
after surgery to remove his prostate he
is cancer free but side effects from the
operation are forcing him to retire
eight years early what kind of loss is
that it's eight years that i don't get
to spend with you know my brothers
in the firehouse eight years that i
don't get to share these this experience
with my son
there's a lot to miss
so this is a high-stakes conversation
and there's some big accusations in
those lawsuits so we've got a lot to say
about them the lawsuits on behalf of the
firefighters are very wide-ranging uh
and far-reaching the plaintiffs uh that
would be the firefighters don't put any
blame on the fire departments that they
served
but in addition to the companies that
make pfas and manufacture turnout gear
the lawsuits name as defendants the
makers of firefighting foam another tool
the trade foam helps fire firefighters
contain the fires it also contains pfas
all these defendants have denied
wrongdoing and they say that the weight
these are the manufacturers and the
makers of the chemicals they say the
weight of the scientific evidence does
not show pfos in their products cause
harm in people at current levels or past
levels and they say that includes cancer
and they add that their products are
safe meet or exceed the applicable
industry standards and enable
firefighters to do their jobs safely and
effectively
but clearly in the firefighting
community there is a change in thinking
about this gear forev for a long time
you wore it like all the time you take
it you'd wear it into the into the
firehouse even and now they realize well
the soot could be cancerous and now the
thinking has gone beyond that and said
well the gear itself may actually be a
problem is there a discrepancy over who
is measuring these tests that determine
cancer
no cancer the measurements are really
solid now the question is the effect and
that's been worked out you know we've
always thought that firefighters are
superheroes which they are but it's
almost like
their superhero uniform was lined with
kryptonite yeah that's the accusation
and that's what's so devious and hard to
wrap your head around is like wow the
thing meant to protect them may have
been hurting them uh if that is
conclusive i think that you know
everyone's rooting for a change for the
next generation